shall we get started so
um
let's see it's a it's a real pleasure to
have uh patrick hayden uh
uh from from stanford university uh
talking to us today so
i should say patrick is one of my
favorite
speakers and thinkers and you know
people to talk to
he
he of course has worked extensively on
quantum information and computation
and on the study of black hole physics
and quantum gravity
but what what i find particularly
you know nice about patrick's work is it
it always provides a
new twist and a
you know and a new way of looking at
things so
really looking forward to your talk
patrick
all right well thank you very much umesh
for the kind introduction
and i hope that there will be a little
bit of a twist in this in this talk as
well um
there was a twist for me
we'll see if our very distinguished
panelists who know much more about fault
hall and quantum computation than i do
are uh equally surprised
i'm just gonna
work on sharing my screen here
sorry that did not work
can everyone see the presentation
yeah okay great all right so
the
the work that i'm going to tell you
about today
um
is about a very simple goal
and the question was that we we set for
ourselves was what is the simplest
device that you could imagine that would
be capable of supporting a
fault-tolerant quantum memory um a cubit
that you could uh
that could live for some very
significant fraction of time
um i think that we might have
completely failed on the marketing of
this task we wrote the paper we called
it the paper fault tolerant cubit from a
constant number of components which
sounds really boring but i think that
the ideas in uh
underlying all of this are quite
interesting and exciting
and so the
um the paper is joint work with soon won
choi and isaac kim both of them were
post-docs when we did it and they're now
faculty um
and noah shetty and keanu wan who are
graduate students in my group
so by now it's quite exciting there are
multiple approaches to quantum
computation that are
actually you know significantly advanced
and
and capable of controlling uh a
a
a decent number of qubits you you're all
familiar with the google sycamore chip
that was used for a quantum supremacy
demonstration uh trapped ion processors
have very
very good
gate quality and coherence times
and these devices
it's worth actually observing are quite
faithful
implementations of the standard approach
to thinking or to defining quantum
computation in the circuit model um in
each of them there are
easily identified degrees of freedom
inside the the device whether it's the
superconducting chip or the trapped ion
processor uh and
there are control you you can
implement single qubit gates and you can
in a controlled way interact the qubits
in the system with uh
with either their neighbors or qubits
maybe further away in the trapdian
processor and implement uh two qubit
gates
and so these are really kind of almost
uh
very natural implementations of the
circuit model of course there are other
ways of trying to implement quantum
computation um
the topological approach is one that i
think many of us are excited about even
if the experiments have not yet been
able to really get that off the ground
including a couple of years ago a
purported uh
discovery of majorana fermions that
could be used
to
fault tolerantly protect quantum
information and hardware rather than
using
quantum error correcting codes but it
turned out that uh that paper was
retracted and so uh
topological quantum computation uh
implemented in hardware is still
something that is a dream for the future
now there are other implementations that
you may be
potential implementations that you may
be less familiar with
here in the bay area a startup company
called sciquantum
is using silicon photonics
to try to implement a fault-tolerant
quantum computer and in their approach
measurement rather than interaction i
would say plays a starring role
for reasons that are quite similar to
what i'll tell you about today and if
you want to know more about it uh we
have a representative from psy quantum
on the panel later and so he'll be you
can ask them
about what they're doing um
amazon recently also got in the game and
about a year ago they put out a paper uh
describing it an architecture and they
are planning to use superconducting
qubits the transmon architecture
but that superconducting qubit is not
actually being used as the memory of the
computer but rather as a control device
and nanomechanical oscillators would
actually be the memory
registers of the computer um
and they're trying to move towards a a
separation
between control and
and memory similar to what happens in
you know the computers on our desks
where uh
different degrees of freedom are rather
different systems with different
characteristics are optimized for
different tasks and so what i'm going to
be telling you about today has
incorporates aspects of both of these
approaches
we're going to be making use of a hybrid
system with different kinds of qubits
and exploiting their respective
characteristics
with the goal
of reducing the manufacturing control
and calibration requirements for quantum
computing
and i don't really want to claim that
the the device that i'm going to tell
you about is actually going to solve all
the all the problems with quantum
computing the objective of today's talk
is really more uh
to encourage us all to uh to remember
that the despite the progress that has
been made um there there is still a lot
of room for innovation on the
architecture front uh and i think there
are surprises yet to be found
so in the next hour or so my goal is
going to be to explain to you why this
device here
um can you see my cursor actually i
can't see you so
uh yeah
yeah okay great um
so
why this device here which um i said
constant number of components it doesn't
have many components um
can support a fault tolerant qubit and
i'll just sketch out to you um
schematically what the you know what the
components are and how this is working
uh and of course over the course of the
talk i'm going to fill in a lot of the
details
and so there's one controlled qubit here
which i'll call the quantum emitter um
and so it's actually a little bit more
than a cubit but you can think of it as
a quantum dot
or a transmond qubit and it's coupled to
a waveguide and so um it can emit uh
photons or phonons into a waveguide and
those are then
rooted by these switches either into
a first delay line this purple one or a
second delay line the red one or they
can be rooted to this detector and the
detector can measure the qubit in one of
uh
a few different bases and so that's it
that's the that's the device um
and it doesn't have many you know it
doesn't have many parts it only has
these yeah
the only thing that you're really
controlling in a quantum mechanical way
is the emitter you're doing quantum
mechanical measurements with the
detector and then there are these
switches and so you don't have a lot of
uh it's not like a the
um
say the
superconducting
model of uh of ibm or google
where
you have if you're going to have a fault
tolerant memory you're actually going to
be simultaneously controlling hundreds
of individual physical qubits there's
just one device that you really know
this one emitter that you're going to be
pulsing an appropriate way and this is
going to make a qubit
and when i say a fault tolerant qubit
um what we're going to find is that the
logical cubit lifetime well actually
let's just think a little bit about what
we'd expect um
now if you have a delay line
um that is actually a kind of a memory
right and you can say well
um what would i expect naively to be
able to do with this well if i emitted a
qubit into the delay line and the and
the qubit can survive the decoherence
time of the delay line has is some
number then the cubic can survive in
that delay line for for the coherence
time and i'll use coherence time loosely
here incorporating losses and other
forms of noise um
but in fact what we find is that the
logical cube at lifetime grows
exponentially with the square root of
the delay line coherence time and so
marginal improvements in the quality of
the delay line can lead to massive
improvements in the quality of the
logical cuber
and to get us there i'm going to spend
20 minutes or so introducing
um
cluster state quantum computation uh
which was invented by one of our
panelists uh robert rosendorf um i'm
gonna explain how to
use this uh this architecture to make
cluster states and then i'm going to
explain why it's actually fault tolerant
um
and
and on the face of it i mean those of
you who know anything about fault
tolerance this this is going to look
like a terrible way to make a fault
tolerant system because all interactions
are mediated by this one qubit but we'll
see that it actually works very well
so cluster state quantum computation
let's just think first about what a
cluster state is so in a cluster state
there are qubits at the vertices of a
graph and so here i have a graph a
square lattice and i have a qubit at
this vertex at this vertex at this
vertex at this vertex and so on um
and we prepare them in the plus state
the superposition of zero and one the
sigma x plus eigenstate um
and then we entangle nearest neighbors
on the graph and so we'll interact this
top left uh with the one right next to
it uh and the top left with one below it
um
and the interaction is a controlled z
and so what it does is it applies a
phase a minus one phase if both of the
qubits are in the one state and either
otherwise it does nothing
um
and then to actually
that's that's actually yeah at that
point you're done with respect to
interactions between the qubits so you
just um prepare this generic resource
entangled state um
and then the computation is actually
implemented by performing a sequence of
single qubit measurements
one here one here one one here one here
and you just perform some sequence of
single qubit measurements and you
interpret the results uh and that is
actually a way to perform universal
quantum computation
um and
um
robert rosendorff and uh and his uh
uh
collaborator hans bregel back in 2001
proved that the 2d square lattice um
with this architecture was universal for
quantum computation and then about five
years later in collaboration with uh jim
harrington in 2006
robert showed that if you made instead a
three-dimensional cubic lattice that
would not just be universal but
fault-tolerant and of course if you want
to
implement non-trivial quantum
computation at the end of the day you
need it to be fault tolerant
now an important observation that uh
that was made early on um was that the
sequence of single qubit measurements
could be organized so that you performed
the measurements column by column on
this cluster state and so i made this uh
this pink uh
vertical line here
and
i should say if anyone wants to ask a
question you should interrupt me um i
can't actually see everybody because of
uh
i'm actually seeing my presentation so
just to just speak up if you want to ask
a question
yeah i had a question
the last person i expected to have a
question
yeah um
so let's let me hold back and see if
there's questions from the audience
not the case okay so i had a question
because you said
you get by with a small number of
components and
if you compare this for example to the
ibm device you have many components so
this emitter thing
that you have there on this maybe two
slides back or so
what is it supposed to represent should
we think of it as
one
protected qubit
or one no i'll i will actually get into
that in more detail later okay so i'll
defer the answer to that question
yeah
okay so we can measure column by column
uh so we measure the first column
then the second column third and so on
like this
and once you've realized that you can do
that
uh
then
uh you realize that it's not actually
necessary to have the entire cluster
state prepared all at once that if you
just prepare the first two columns
then the first column at that point has
interacted with all of the qubits that
it will ever interact with and so then
you're free to actually measure them
away so you could prepare two columns
and then measure the first
and then prepare the third column
and measure the second column and
continue like that
and so one dimension of the lattice can
be effectively constructed in time
rather than space
uh and so that's actually an important
feature of the way that cluster state
quantum computation is imp is expected
to be implemented in practice
now
how do you actually use this to perform
a quantum computation uh this uh this
figure is actually taken from a figure
of a paper of roberts
i'll just sketch this out to you
the first step is actually going to be
to
measure away a number of the qubits in
the cluster and so in this diagram
everywhere
every site with an arrow or a circle is
a
a site in the cluster and the first step
we're going to do is we're going to
measure away these uh these circle sites
that's measuring in the sigma z eigen
basis
um and the effect of that is to
eliminate qubits from the cluster and to
see why
um here i have a very little cluster
state
and remember that these gates are
controlled zeds and i said that control
zed was applying a phase of minus one if
both of the qubits are in the one state
it's the same thing as saying that if
you look
at one of the qubits and it's in the
zero state you do nothing and
if it's in the one state you apply a z
gate
so let's imagine now that we've measured
the last qubit in the sigma z eigen
basis so we learned whether it's a zero
or a one
in that case um we will have learned
whether this controlled z gate applied
the identity or the z
right and so if applied the id
in the case that we measure a zero
nothing happened in the case that we
measured a one this gate applied a z the
the controlled zeta plot applied to z
and from an entanglement perspective
these states have the same structure um
and from the cluster state quantum
computation perspective uh the effect of
having this
uh paul lee zed
applied after the fact is just we'll
just require you to change your
interpretation of some of the
measurement results as you as you go
forward but as long as you keep track
it it is effectively
still the cluster state
now so
so that once we've measured away a
number of the qubits we're left with uh
a structure like the one that i've uh
that robert drew here um
and
you can see there's some kind of
implicitly it looks like there's maybe
some information flow running from left
to right and let's see how you can
actually get quantum information to
propagate
through
through a line of this cluster state and
so imagine that we have some qubit that
was part of a cluster state and maybe
had participated in some quantum
computation
and now we want to try to move that the
quantum information of that qubit to
another qubit in the cluster state
the first thing to observe is that the
first qubit is decohered in the sigma z
eigen basis
why is that well we have we apply to
control z gate and so if the first qubit
was zero nothing happens if the first
qubit was one uh it changes the phase of
the second cube and turns the plus into
a minus and so the second qubit records
whether the first qubit was in the zero
or one state
and so if we measure the first qubit
in a basis conjugate to zed
we will not learn anything about the
state on the first qubit we will not
learn anything about psi the uh the
measurement results will be uh
probability of half one and probability
of half zero
and it's a you know one of those basic
facts about quantum information that
measurements that reveal no information
at least in the church of the larger
hilbert space picture they don't also
don't destroy any information and so psy
must survive this measurement um
and get propagated to the second qubit
and when you do the little calculation
the way that it gets propagated is that
there's first a hadamard gate and then
depending on the outcome of the of the
measurement on the first qubit there's a
z or there isn't a z
and so a sequence of x measurements can
act as a wire propagating quantum
information uh to the right through the
system and so here you can see some the
components that i've highlighted are
acting as a wire uh or as three wires
propagating information from left to
right
now
if we instead chose a different conjuga
a different basis to measure that was
still
conjugate to z but was rotated uh in the
x y plane
so
we uh conjugate this x
operator by uh some rotation about the
z-axis um
what is the effect of that
well
a unitary
that rotates about the z-axis commutes
with this controlled z operator and so
its effect uh we could actually just
move this uh this unitary uzed onto psi
um and so the effect is again to
propagate the information but with the
uh the unitary applied to psi itself as
well and so this gives us a way to uh
apply at least rotations about the
z-axis to input states
but if you notice that there's also this
hadamard sitting there if we perform
such measurements in succession
we end up conjugating these rotations by
hadamard gates
and the effect of a hat well if we
conjugate the x
uh an x operator by a hadamard we get a
z if we conjugate a z by a hadamard we
get an x and so
um
the effect is that we'll be able to
perform rotations both around the z-axis
and around the x-axis and thanks to uh
leonard euler we learned that we can
perform arbitrary rotations by uh
performing a sequence of three rotations
one around around z around x and around
z again
and so we can perform arbitrary
rotations and then arbitrary su-2
transformations this way
and so
these sections of the
uh
of the sequence of measurements that
i've highlighted in pink correspond to
some single qubit gates arbitrary single
cubic gates being applied
um and so now we've learned that we can
perform arbitrary single qubit gates and
you know you probably remember from your
studies of universal quantum computation
that if you can perform every single
qubit gate then if you supplement that
by any non-trivial two-qubit gate you
get universality
and so
the structures here that i've
highlighted in green by the same
argument that i wrote above
the measurements aren't going to reveal
anything about the incoming information
so they're going to perform some
non-trivial unitary transformations on
the two qubits and so we have
universality and it turns out the
non-trivial unitary transformation
applies is the form of the control z
there as well
so that's it that's uh that is basically
the proof uh robert's proof that um
that
clusters the cluster state architecture
is universal for quantum computing
and
um it may not be the most efficient way
to make use of this resource right
because we're just actually translating
a circuit into uh the cluster state
architecture but it's a demonstration
that uh of universality and from then
you can try to optimize uh computations
for use in this architecture
now to good um to get fault tolerance
again robert and jim harrington
demonstrated this could be done by going
to a three-dimensional cluster state
so what is the idea there
the idea
i'm not going to draw the individual
qubits here but time is again running
from left to right and so i have
uh
i have a cluster state um
that is organized in planes you know
might what were columns before right now
are are now planes like this either the
purple plane and the next to another one
and so on um
and
we're going to encode the quantum
information in each one of those planes
into a planar quantum error correcting
code like the torque code
um and you could imagine using the the
circuit description or the the circuit
translation that i just described to you
encoding uh a state of the torah code
and then performing the error correction
as you go along um using the the tools
that we described before that is
actually not the most efficient yeah the
best way to to do this that you can work
more uh
natively uh with the cluster state but
at least from the point of view of uh
intuition that uh that can give you an
idea about how you would in you would
get uh how you would encode um and
protect quantum information inside a
three-dimensional cluster state by using
a two-dimensional quantum error
correcting code
so using again this more native
description of how you would actually
protect quantum information yet or
make use of the torque code in the
cluster state
robert and jim
found that if you applied random poly
noise and so basically uh depolarizing
noise um there was a surprisingly high
threshold for this architecture that you
could at every time step um corrupt
every qubit with probability 0.58
percent uh and that and still be able to
recover uh
and perform universal quantum
computation and so this is one of the
the great virtues of this architecture
noticed uh again it's been known for 15
years is that the threshold is actually
remarkably high
and
after their original paper
subsequent optimizations pushed the
threshold up almost to one percent
now a little aside on fault tolerance
circuit design
here i have a qubit
then being encoded into so
my horizontal line here should be
you should think of that as a single
qubit i have a quantum state psi and
then i encode it into seven qubits i
want this to be an error correcting code
um so i'll call the encoded state
sidebar
and let's suppose that the code can
correct for an arbitrary error on one
unknown qubit any error happening
anywhere
it's important not just to be able to
encode information but to be able to act
on the physical degrees of freedom to
compute and we can ask well how yeah
how do you compute on encoded data the
first thing that might come to mind is
you might say well let's just act on on
one of the physical qubits to see if we
can do something non-trivial uh and of
course you can't do anything non-trivial
acting on a single qubit uh because that
would be indistinguishable from the
noise that the code was designed
to correct against and so that's not
going to
do anything nontrivial to the encoded
state
um
so your next idea might be well let's
act on more than one qubit at a time so
here i have this operator w that's going
to act on a pair of qubits and that can
do something nontrivial to the state
potentially at the encoded state
however
if an error occurred on one of the
qubits prior to the application of this
w
gate um
if we commute the error past the gate
we'll have two errors um one act uh
acting on two different qubits uh and
this code is not designed to protect
against two errors anymore um
and
and so we were taken outside of the uh
the realm of correctability potentially
by applying this kind of game
and so what do we do instead um
we have we want gates that act on
multiple qubits but they act on multiple
qubits independently and so here i have
uh
four unitaries each acting on a single
qubit and this and with this setup if we
have an error acting on a single gate or
a rather on a single qubit if we commute
the error past the gate it's still an
error acting on a single qubit and
that's going to be correctable and so
this was an aside on
i just want to seed this uh this
discussion in your minds uh and the
reason is going to be basically that
the architecture that i'm going to
propose
seems to violate
this uh
rule of thumb that is often um
guiding our design our approach
designing fault taller quantum circuits
which is to avoid gates that can
propagate errors between physical qubits
um our architecture is going to be about
as bad on that front as you could
possibly imagine
all right so how do you prepare cluster
states using one of these single
emitters well first robert was asking
you know what how should how you should
think of this emitter um
in the simplest uh in the simplest
version we're gonna to ours is a little
bit more complicated than this but um
there was a proposal due to linder and
rudolph back in 2009 to prepare
one-dimensional cluster states um with a
quantum dot so that's what
they were
and a waveguide and the quantum dot was
assumed to have a level structure like
i've shown here the the zero and the one
were two different energy levels and
then there was a another level energy
level
such that you could drive transitions
from the one up to this excited state e
and then the uh
if the system was in the e state it
would rapidly decay back to the one uh
emitting a pulse into the waveguide
and so
um if the system was in zero you don't
get a pulse in the waveguide if this
system was if the emitter wasn't one
then you do get a pulse and so uh the
inside the waveguide uh a zero
corresponded to no pulse and a one
corresponded to a pulse
um
and
by driving transitions between zero and
one you can make the hadamard gate by
driving transitions between the one and
the excited state you can basically
perform the controlled x gate between
the emitter uh and and these uh these
waveguide uh waveguide qubits and so
this was a way to make a one-dimensional
cluster state um
yeah using the an emitter and a
waveguide
a few years ago one of my co-authors
sunwahn choi and uh and his co-authors
um pointed out that with a relatively
simple extension of this linder rudolph
architecture you could make a
two-dimensional cluster state and there
and thereby actually make it a resource
universal for quantum computation
and the idea was to use the same quantum
emitter
but um it emitted say to the left you
know in the left direction so these it
emitted one of these blue pulses into a
waveguide
that then bounced uh the pulses would
eventually bounce off a mirror come back
interact with the emitter a second time
and then
travel to the right as these red pulses
and then eventually be measured if you
wanted to perform quantum computation
so
why does this actually make a 2d cluster
state
um you could imagine a 1d cluster state
you know it's just a line so you could
take your line and you could wrap it
in a spiral right
um
now
the sending the the pulses first towards
the mirror and then coming back has the
effect of just implementing a delay
before they interact with the emitter
again
and so
um
i have this spiral of pulses now um
and a blue pulse comes back to the
emitter and
interacts with the emitter thereby
creating the opportunity to establish
entanglement with a pulse which is going
to be created later or being created at
that time and so that gives you the
opportunity to create
um
these uh
my spiral is on its side here and so
that uh links between different levels
in the spiral and so i i've uh i have a
picture here of trajan's column right so
trajan's in trajan's column there's a
story which is happening and it's
wrapping around the column uh and so
there's a there you know there's
definitely a direction of time uh which
corresponds you know to this
one-dimensional uh
one-dimensional depiction of a scene
but the
the occupants of uh of the scene at one
level could actually reach up and touch
the toes of the people at uh at a time
in the future right and that's basically
what this uh delay in the waveguide
allows you to do it allows you to create
a cluster state which is wrapped around
a cylinder and so that's a
two-dimensional object and that's going
to be universal for quantum computation
and of course the next natural step is
the three-dimensional uh cluster state
um
now the abstract problem that we're
going to have to solve
um you know where we can you know strip
away a lot of the complicate
complications just to prepare a cluster
state using interactions only between
this emitter and the emitter is the
the part the object that we can control
and data qubits and the data qubits have
no two two qubit gates between them
there are only two qubit gates um
the only gates at all
are on the emitter and two cubic gates
from the emitter to one of the data
qubits
and the simplest solution for making a
cluster state you know subject to these
constraints is to use swap gates
so here i want to make a little
triangular cluster state and i have a
my emitter q
so what could i do
i could first apply controlled z
um between the emitter and and the first
uh
qubit that's supposed to be part of the
cluster state and then i could swap q
into the position of the two qubit
um and then i could apply two more
controlled sets uh
and then swap q into the into the third
position and then i would have made my
cluster state done right
now
the obstacle to doing that uh for us is
going to be that we're now concerned
about fault tolerance and so we're not
going to want to use exactly the same
setup that linder and rudolph and then
pickler and troy were using because
we're going to want our data qubits to
be dual rail
and what that means is that instead of
the presence or absence of a pulse
in the waveguide corresponding to a
qubit the timing of the pulse is going
to correspond uh to the state of the
qubit um and the reason for doing that
is that this makes losses in the
waveguide detect uh detectable
and detectable loss errors are
orders of magnitude more benign uh than
um than losses that when you don't know
that they've happened and so if you uh
if the presence or absence of a qubit or
of a pulse um was your qubit then when
there's a loss you don't know whether uh
whether that was a zero or a lost qubit
but if you use a dual rail qubit then uh
then losses are much more more benign
the price we pay for that though is that
we don't actually have a natural way to
implement the swap gate
but it turns out that a swamp followed
by a controlled zed and you'll remember
that we have you know that's the kind of
thing that we want to actually do um is
equivalent to a c naught followed by a
hadamard um provided the target state
you know that you're applying this c
naught to uh is in the zero state and
the initial state um that you're going
to swap with was in a plus state um so
remember that the first step of
preparing a cluster state was to prepare
the plus so instead we're going to
actually start off with our data qubits
and the zero and then apply controlled
knots and hadamards
all right so let's actually just uh see
how we would use this setup to make a 2d
cluster state before we make the 3d
cluster state so this is drawn a little
bit differently than before i have my
emitter
and it's going to emit into this
waveguide whose length
is designed to allow l time steps um and
after l time steps the uh
the propagating qubit and the waveguide
is going to come back and interact with
the emitter a second time and then get
measured ultimately
all right so the first thing we'll do is
we're going to apply a a c naught
and then a hadamard
um so that's going to generate our first
pulse
and so there's going to be a pulse in in
the waveguide and remember that the c
naught and the and then the hadamard is
the same as a swap and
and then a controlled set and so that
actually just establishes um
an entangled state between the emitter
and the first qubit
and then we're going to do the same
thing we're going to apply a c naught
and another hadamard and let's just
actually think about what that's going
to do
so a c naught and then a hadamard is
going to be the same as swapping q
into the second position and then
applying another controlled z-gate
so we swapped the emitter state into the
second position and the emitter had been
entangled with one and so we have this
we have the first link in our cluster
state and then we also have the emitter
entangled with two
and then we do it again
um
and
now we have the third
qubit of our cluster state
and qubits one two three are propagating
through the waveguide and one is about
to come back to the emitter
so one comes back to the emitter and
when it comes back to the emitter it
interacts with the emitter and
implements a controlled z so there's my
control zed
and that established this link between
one and the emitter uh in my my current
uh
my current uh
quantum quantum state
and then
i apply my c naught hadamard combination
which swaps q into position four
um
and so i've actually now started
creating the second row of my cluster
state and then i just repeat this repeat
this repeat and so on and this way i
actually make the spiraling
two-dimensional cluster state
and to get the 3d cluster state you
really actually just have to do the same
thing um and so i can't claim there's
really any innovation here we just uh
took the same idea um that uh pickler at
all had come up to make a 2d cluster
state and added a second delay line and
the second delay line allows you to
create another level
and so again just to set things up we
have the emitter the emitter is going to
emit into the waveguide
this first waveguide whose length is l
time steps um
and then it moves into the it it
interacts with the emitter before moving
into the second wave guide
whose length is l squared minus l time
steps so that it it comes back to
interact with the emitter a second time
after a total of l squared time steps l
uh the length of the first waveguide
plus the length of the second waveguide
and my claim is that um
this is going to make the
three-dimensional cluster safe for you
the circuit corresponding to that
sequence of interactions is drawn below
and now i'll highlight
my two different waveguides are now blue
and purple
and when each of the data qubits is
inside one of the waveguides i've
highlighted them in the appropriate
color so the first qubit starts off
propagating through the blue guide and
then
uh interacts with the emitter makes a
controlled zed gate
uh and then moves through the purple
waveguide
um and then interacts with the emitter
again
and this is where things get interesting
um
because qubit 1 at this step interacts
with the emitter a second time
performs a controlled z and when is it
doing that it's doing that right before
we're about to emit a pulse into the
tenth position
and the tenth position is this first
qubit in the second uh the second layer
of the three-dimensional cluster state
and so
this controlled zed that happens when
the
uh the first qubit comes out of the
purple waveguide uh corresponds to
establishing the first length uh
into the screen right between the first
layer of the cluster state and the
second layer of the cluster state and so
you just repeat
and um
and this is going to make the
three-dimensional cluster state for you
now
again there's no real innovation there
um
and in fact it seems like a bad idea and
the reason it seems like a bad idea is
that this this architecture looks like
it could
potentially propagate errors quite badly
um
because
every interaction is mediated by this
emitter
every qubit interacts only with the
emitter and so errors in the emitter
seem like they're going to propagate all
over the circuit
and that seems to avoid this rule of
thumb that we should not we should
design fault tolerance circuits in such
a way that they don't propagate errors
between physical cubits
so let's see if that actually happens
suppose that there's an x error at the
step that i've just indicated here
um
what's you know
what's going to happen if we commute
that x error past the first controlled
zed uh then we're going to have errors
on the emitter and now on qubit two and
we can we commute past the second
controlled zed we're now gonna have an
error on the emitter on qubit two on
qubit five and and you can you know you
can look at what's going to happen do
the algebra
and this single x error by the time
you're done constructing your cluster
state is going to be a collection of
errors on half of the half of all the
data qubits
and so this is this looks like a worst
case scenario um this is like a
like an epidemic where the doctor is
contagious uh and she's going from house
to house
infecting all of you know all of the
previously uh healthy
healthy patients in her during her her
house calls um
this like this is this really does not
seem like a good way to design a fault
tolerant circuit preparation or cluster
state preparation scheme
at this point though it's useful to step
back and think about the cluster state a
little bit more abstractly not in terms
of the circuit that prepares it but
instead in terms of its algebraic
properties and so the certain the
cluster state can be characterized as
the unique plus one eigenstate of a set
of commuting operators so it's it's a
it's a stabilizer state um
if you're familiar with that language
and so for each vertex in the cluster
state uh there's an operator and so so
say for the eighth the uh
the eighth qubit uh
here
the operator would be to apply an x on
qubit eight and then zeds on each of the
neighboring qubits so a zed on seven a
zed on two a zed on 9 is that on 11 and
there might be some other ones because
remember there are these periodic
boundary conditions but they're not
drawn here
and so the stabilizer associated with uh
site 8 qubit 8 is this one here with
site 10 is this one here it's always uh
an x on the site and then z's on all of
the neighbors
well
because the cluster state is left
invariant by these stabilizer operators
we could act on the cluster state by
these operators and it's not going to
affect the cluster state and so the
um
the errors that we get
that have been propagated through the
whole circuit
are equivalent to the multiplication of
the reds uh in each row with the blues
that i've drawn here each each blue
column the first blue corresponds to the
s8 stabilizer the second blue column
corresponds to the s10 stabilizer and
remember the pali operator square to the
identity and so we actually now don't
have an error on qubit two we don't have
an error on qubit four we don't have an
error on qubit five ah but z cubed is an
error so we do have an error on qubit
seven and so on
and
so all of those errors that we
propagated through the circuit
um where we actually damaged we it
looked like we had damaged half of the
qubits in the cluster state they're
actually equivalent to a single error a
z error on the seventh qubit um and this
seems like a small miracle but it's
actually true in general any single
qubit circuit error you know gate error
um becomes an error supported um in the
neighborhood of a single qubit of the
cluster state
um and to see why um
i i erased an observation here so we're
gonna go straight to number two um
the key point is that at every step of
this uh cluster state preparation
circuit the um
the quantum state is actually a cluster
state it's not necessarily the cluster
state that we want that it's not our
final cluster state but it's some
cluster state and so we can use the
reasoning to think about what would
happen uh if there were
the x error at this time that i uh that
i indicated earlier
um
so the x error is on the emitter so i'll
put the x on the emitter and this is a
cluster state
there's a stabilizer operator associated
with the emitter now which is an x on
the emitter and a z on its neighbors and
so there's a z on seven and so this x
error on the emitter is just equivalent
uh to a z error on uh on site seven and
that's what we saw earlier that this uh
what looked like a spray of errors all
over the circuit is actually equivalent
in this case to a single qubit error um
on a single data qubit
let's look at a another example
so
if we had an error again let's say it's
an x error
uh at this site in the circuit um that
that is an
and let's say it's an error on the
emitter again
um
the stabilizer for the emitter oops um
is an x on the emitter and zed's on
qubit four and qubit seven and so we can
turn this x error on the emitter into z
errors on four and seven
and then
the next c naught and hadamard is going
to swap the emitter into site ten
oops uh and so
these errors are going to be errors on
uh
these two z errors are going to be zed
errors
in a neighborhood of site 10 in the in
the cluster state
and so this is the essential reason that
what looked like a terrible architecture
for uh
for building a fault tolerant um quantum
memory actually is much better than one
would expect
so how well does this work um
we
looked at you know we
we studied this question um for a
standard model of depolarizing noise and
so uh after every single qubit operation
a gate a measurement or state
preparation uh we have depolarizing
noise um with some probability and after
two cubic gates we have two qubit
depolarizing noise um again with the
same error probability
and
we could find the threshold again the
way that you find the threshold is by
noticing that above thresholds trying to
perform this air correction makes things
worse above threshold or below threshold
trying to perform the air correction
makes things better and so the point
where these lines all cross is the point
where the threshold is and we find a
threshold probability
um error probability of 0.39
this is a little bit worse than what
rust endorphin harrington found they had
0.58
but we expected it to be worse right
because single qubit errors as we found
can propagate to errors on a
neighborhood of a single qubit uh in the
in the final cluster state um
but it's not it's not terribly worse so
we've paid a price but it's a reasonable
price um this is still quite a high
threshold
and
in many cases
the dominant form of noise and the
waveguide is going to be loss noise and
remember we went through we jumped
through some hoops in order to be able
to uh make losses detectable um and so
we could we actually calculated the the
the threshold for combinations of losses
in the waveguide uh and
gate errors um in the circuit
and you can see here if there's no loss
so loss is zero we have the 0.39 percent
uh
gate level uh
error threshold
but
if there's actually no if there are no
gate errors if they were if they were if
the gates were noiseless uh then we can
actually tolerate losses in the
waveguide up to about 22 percent and so
this is you know this this is why uh as
i said loss air detectable loss errors
are much more benign than uh
undetectable loss errors you can lose a
macroscopic fraction of all of the
cubits in the waveguide and still be
able to actually um
preserve your logical cubit
now
that is not quite the end of the story
however um
because
remember
we
we are keeping our qubits in the delay
line and the delay line uh the longer
the delay line the more losses uh the
qubits are likely to incur or rather the
more loss uh there is going to be at
some point if you make your delay line
too long all of your qubits you know all
of your pulses are going to be lost and
there will be no uh no quantum
information uh to speak of um
and so instead of a strict threshold
like i was describing before what we
actually get is that the logical cubit
lifetime scales as
exponentially in the square root of the
delay line coherence time
and to see why that is um we can kind of
argue it heuristically
we're using a topological code you know
the torah code uh inside the cluster
state
um and so logical operations in the
torah code are topological which means
that to
incur a logical error you need a
sequence of errors inside yeah
inside the um in
inside the turret code uh
that look like a topologically
non-trivial loop
or
cycle
and
the probability of that happening if the
error rate is low um scales
exponent is exponentially small in the
linear size
of the torah code now this is the uh the
standard uh
standard fact about topological quantum
error correction and the reason that we
the reason that we like it the larger
the topology the larger the system uh
the smaller the errors now in our case
um
the
delay line error probability as i was
saying grows with the size of the
grows with the
size of the delay line and the the total
length of the delay line is l squared
and so the delay line error probability
uh is eta time you know where eta times
l squared where eta is the delay line
error rate
and so we have this trade-off we're
increasing the linear size of the
cluster state decreases the logical
error probability provided or below
threshold but increasing the linear size
of the cluster state eventually causes
us to exceed the threshold and not be
able to perform any useful error
correction at all
and so what you would expect is that
there's going to be some optimal size
for your cluster state um
where
the error the delay line total delay
line error probability uh eta times l
squared is about the threshold
probability for the torque code
and
if you just substitute in that
expression for l into the logical error
probability
what you find is that the logical error
probability is going to scale
exponentially with minus one over
the delay line error rate which is just
another way of saying that the logical
qubit lifetime is going to scale
exponentially with the uh the lifetime
of a qubit in the delay line
so that was a heuristic argument but we
verified this experimentally the
agreement is yeah
is uh
is very good
um
and then we can find you know using what
we think are realistic estimates for um
different parameters in the in the
problem uh well actually we we can just
find that um there's a break-even point
for losses that if we just fix the gate
error probability at 10 to the minus 3
so that we're below threshold for the
gate errors
then we break even
with a loss probability of 7.4 times
times 10 to the minus 4.
um
and again
making
for optical fiber if we had 17 uh
uh a delay of 17 nanoseconds between
photons um the loss rate is in the same
vicinity about 9.6 times 10 to the minus
4. so we're right around
we're not quite at the point where this
would be useful um if we were actually
implementing this with optical fiber but
we're not so far off and of course
optical fiber has been optimized
relentlessly for commercial reasons so
we don't expect to have massive
improvements in the quality of optical
fiber soon
but if you could improve um current
technology by a factor about 20 then you
could push the logical error rate down
to about 10 to the minus 10
if you improved another two and a half
times because the power of exponentials
you can get the logical error
probability down to about 10 to the
minus 15.
um
and that's the that's essentially the
story i guess i will i will just say
briefly um
the there are many different possible
architectures or you know physical
realizations of this approach and i
think that the
the most
likely to be viable may not actually be
um say a quantum dot coupled to optical
fiber but instead a transmond qubit
coupled piezoelectrically to a
nanomechanical oscillator uh or
nanomechanical waveguide uh and so we
have an expert on that kind of
technology on the panel amir naini
safavi and so we can we can get his
views on how realistic it is for that to
actually happen um
and so
what have we actually done here
the goal was to find a way of building a
fault tolerant qubit um using as few
components as possible as as simply
the simplest possible technology
and i think we we have a proposal which
is very simple it turns out that the
quality of the components is not uh
exceeds what is currently available
technologically uh
but because they're very few of them at
some point once we cross these
thresholds and uh you know and cry
across the break-even point at that
point any every marginal improvement um
is going to lead to uh
tremendous improvements in lifetime and
again i'll just stress that um
with respect to the emitter it is
sufficient to get the emitter error rate
down below threshold like 10 to the
minus three and then at that point um
improvements only in the quality of the
waveguide uh will lead to dramatic
improvements in the lifetime of the
logical cubit
um
we also found that despite the seemingly
brain-dead design of this system
that that looked like it would be
terrible from the point of view of fault
tolerance uh it nonetheless actually um
stores quantum information quite well
and and even though it does propagate
errors it doesn't uh it propagates
errors in a way which is completely
benign because of the um
the stabilizer structure of the of the
uh cluster state
and the just to finally reiterate my
um the big point that i want to make
here
is that people studying fault tolerance
and quantum computation for many many
years made uh the simplifying assumption
that all of the qubits that they were
going to be working with um were of the
same type they had similar control
characteristics and noise
characteristics and then you designed a
fault tolerant system to deal with that
with those problems but experimentalists
taught us and i think last week michelle
deveras spoke in this uh this uh in the
setting was actually their work that in
some ways inspired me to start looking
at uh at hybrid systems
experimentalists taught us that um in
realistic physical systems you will
often have access to different kinds of
qubits with very different properties
and that's a lever that we can exploit
and i think it is happening these days
to you know to some extent but i think
it's really a direction that us
theorists should really be pushing hard
on um because we can see here
um that it's the ratio of time scales
associated with two different kinds of
qubits that actually defines the the
logical cubit lifetime in this setting
and so leveraging the differences
between qubits can be very advantageous
um and at the same time or the other
thing that i think we should should be
pushing on some of the
rules of thumb that we have uh have
worked by or you know sort of labored
with um in our design of fault quantum
circuits may actually be restricting us
um and preventing us from looking at uh
at architectures that may actually be
more powerful and more effective than we
thought and on that note i will um i
will stop
thank you for your attention
great um thank you uh patrick that was a
that was a superb talk
really beautiful so um
let's see if there any questions i i
know andrew had uh
had several questions in the chat but uh
but maybe he can speak up himself
uh sure i also enjoyed your talk very
much patrick thank you
um i did write a couple of questions in
the chat i guess you can read them at
your leisure later i will uh maybe just
say them briefly here though
first i i you said that having constant
components was maybe banal at the
beginning but i actually found it rather
jarring because when i think of fault
tolerance i think about doing an
arbitrarily uh precise simulation of an
ideal process using faulty components
and it sounds like you just have a
constant number of components to get you
an arbitrarily good
um
you know simulation of course it's the
constant number of components but
presumably this delay line has to get
longer and longer
you know something must have to scale um
otherwise uh it doesn't make any sense i
mean in that same notion you could say
traditional fault tolerance all you need
are qubits and a constant number of
gates and that's it and you can do you
know anything so something must have to
grow to do arbitrarily good precision
simulations of an ideal circuit right
and am i right that it's really the
length of the delay lines that that
grows here or what is it the scales i
guess to do that's exactly right it's
the it's the length of the delay line
and so
um
yeah so something something has to scale
but it's something that you don't have
to control right and so i i treat the
delay line as a single component um but
the longer it is um
potential well
um
as we found there's a there's an optimal
length for the delay line that depends
on the error the the error rate in the
delay line that if you make the delay
line too long um then you're going to
push you're going to end up above
threshold and you're not going to be
able to perform any error correction uh
and so you find the optimal length of
the delay line and then that tells you
what your logical cubit lifetime is
going to be
okay so i would say that's not fault
tolerant but perhaps gives you a very
good quality qubit much of the way that
modern transistors are not fault
tolerant but they're very very robust to
error so we don't worry about it
yeah so if you if you define fault
tolerant as um allowing you to perform
arbitrarily or you know to preserve the
the cubit memory as long as you want
then it won't be fault tolerant but um
with some not terribly scary parameters
you can get logical cubit lifetimes that
go like you know that are 10 to the 15
uh circuit steps um and then yeah for
all intents and purposes that's fault
tolerant
okay
the other question i have is maybe more
to sort of tee up a conversation between
you and danny lotinsky who i see is on
the line here and is also a panelist
which is that the architecture that
we've proposed sounds to me very similar
to this uh so-called interleaving
architecture that's like quantum has
proposed for their fusion-based quantum
computing architecture where they um
again are using you know emitters if you
will that are connected and there's this
l squared story in the exponential story
and they reuse them over and over again
of course they're mimicking uh
fusion-based quantum computation which
uses single and two qubit measurements
effectively as opposed to just creating
a large cluster state and then
propagating the computation with single
qubit measurements but they're very
closely related models
and in fact isaac kim who you said
worked on this also worked on that one
as well so i was wondering if you could
comment maybe a little bit on the
similarities and differences between
these two models
um i think actually that would be
a a good question for for our panelists
i mean my my understanding is that maybe
you can postpone it to the panel and get
to other questions fair enough fair
enough
um actually just to just to follow up on
you know uh some something patrick you
said which was you know we
maybe we should be throwing out some of
the rules of some that we we
had about uh
about fault tolerance um
so one of the rules of thumbs we we we
used to have was um
you know sequential uh
uh computation you know where you have
only one active site
inherently leads to non-fault tolerant
quantum computation you know that you
needed some sort of parallelism where
you had many active sites
and i i think it sounds to me like
you're saying well if you have a very uh
stable memory in the form of this delay
line then of course you can you can you
can keep your qubits on ice so to speak
while you go around
you know sort of working on
you know on them one at a time is that
is that sort of the thing or what yeah
um
i guess that yeah i think your
interpretation is correct now we were
careful in the title of this paper to
say fault-tolerant cubit rather than
fault-tolerant quantum computer
because we've really only made one qubit
or
you know with this torque code you could
make a small number of qubits but
because there is some maximum size for
the cluster state at any given noise
rate in the delay line you're not going
to be able to pack as many qubits as you
would like inside that cluster state
right that you're you yeah the more you
pack in
the
um
the weaker the error correction prop uh
properties of the cluster or of the
torah code are going to be and so
we basically are going to be able to get
a a small number of qubits in there and
so we can only perform quantum
computation on a small number of qubits
and so to turn this into an architecture
fully fledged architecture for quantum
computing i think you would actually
need to
connect up uh a number of systems that
look like this and so we've thought a
little bit about that but not too much
about how you would uh have basically
one emitter per logical qubit and so
then there would act then you would
actually be
um
requiring some level of parallelism
because you'd be working uh you'd have a
number of these going at once um but
less parallelism than you might have
expected
sorry um so the the thing that um you
just said um
um
i'm still not quite so you have many of
these logical qubits and then how do you
um is there a way to say how you would
interact between them oh yeah well so
what you basically need to do is you
would need to stitch together um maybe a
better way to think about it is
that
each one of these emitters with their
own delay lines can make a can make a
um
well
at any given time what it what it
actually has sitting inside its delay
lines is basically one layer
of the turret code yeah in the three
dimensional cluster state
and so what you would need to what you
really want to do is stitch together
those patches of torque code to make a
larger torque code and then it inside
that larger torque code you would you
know you'd puncture it in various ways
to store uh to have lot more quantum
information that you could you could
work with and so what would need to
happen
is that um phonons or photons you know
from the waveguide associated with one
of the emitters would be transferred in
uh into a waveguide for another emitter
uh where it could then interact with
that emitter in order to
perform the appropriate controlled zeds
to actually stitch up a larger cluster
state
[Music]
and then from there again the the single
qubit measurements allow you to do
whatever you want with that larger
cluster state including you know fault
tolerant quantum computation
great
um
yeah
um
any other any other questions andrea do
you have you been monitoring that yeah
there are some questions in the q a
so oliver is asking uh could you
elaborate on the dual rail encoding
system so which modes of the data qubits
represent the state
and why does this lead to detectable
loss errors oh sure um
so
the level structure for our emitter
um
basically has um an excited state for
both the zero and the one um instead of
just an
excited state for the one and so we
uh at different times we would pulse the
zero and the one um
and if this if the quantum if our
emitter was in the zero state um and we
pulsed the uh the transition corp yeah
that leads to the zero the excite the
excited state for zero then we would end
up with a pulse in the waveguide at that
time for the zero state and
then we pulse for the one state
um and if the system was in the one
state then we'll end up with a pulse in
the waveguide for the corresponding to
the
uh the one state and so the
the qubit state in the waveguide um
really is just a time bin
uh qubit
and so
um
let's say that the if the pulse arrives
early that's a zero and if the pulse
arrives late that's a one um
but the reason the losses are detectable
is that in both cases there is a pulse
um and so if there's a loss and the
pulse and if one of the pulses
disappears when we when we go to measure
we'll notice oh there was no pulse um
and therefore uh there was a loss error
so that's the that's the point
uh so i think there's another question
but this was basically answered already
it's how you
allow you know logical case between
multiple qubits i think you partially
answered this okay
okay if there aren't any any more
questions um then let's um
let's go on to the panel so if
you can have the videos the panelists
pinned up
um
so um
i think you all at this point know who
the panelists are we have a very
distinguished panel who who
represent
various aspects of this